what's the most annoying thing in the
world an unhappy billionaire and i think
he said something like that i was like
wow that's so true actually like if he
came to me about being glum and whatever
it would be hard for me and my initial
reaction to be like dude you have it
i all like i can rule the world i know i
could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right let's get into it you ready
yeah
ah all right what's going on
not too much
um can i tell you uh a quick story that
i just read
i love when we start with the story the
last the last story uh got rave reviews
big reaction for the psychedelic story
oh did it
great all right let me tell you a quick
one this isn't about me though and i'm
and i'm actually reading the book called
story worthy because you told me it was
a good book but uh and so i haven't read
it enough that i'm gonna implement what
it's what i've learned so don't have
your high expectations but i'm reading
the biography of the wright brothers do
you know who they are of course that's
the airplane well you didn't know who
dolly was first people to to
have a flying plane yeah that's good
yeah the the wright brothers they uh
they created like insulin right um so
wilbur wright was like the smart was
like the smart brother or he was like
the lead brother and when he was in high
school
he was very smart he was gonna go to
yale he was like the it was gonna be a
big deal and he was an athlete and he
was out one night playing hockey in the
neighborhood uh he lived in ohio dayton
ohio where it was really cold in the
winter and you could you could play ice
hockey on the lakes and he was playing
and this kid comes from behind him and
smacks him in the face with a stick and
he knocks out most of his teeth he
breaks his jaw and he has digestive
problems for years and he's basically
like not in a coma but he's like he
doesn't he doesn't leave his house for
four years the guy who hit him his name
is um
like howard
howard hoth or something like that and
he this guy this kid who hit him one of
the reasons why it's hypothesized why he
hit him is this kid had been suffering
from a cold or some type of flu for a
really long time and the at the time
they gave him this medicine that was
cocaine-based and so basically he was
like a drug addict at a young age and he
was a bully he was known to be a bully
and he smacked uh wilbur right the face
really bad no one knows if it was on
accident if it was on purpose turns out
years later this guy who hit him uh
turns out to be one of the first serial
killers based out of ohio and he's put
to death because he kills like 20 people
so he was like a bad guy for for from
since the beginning and he hits wolver
right in the face and so wilbur wright
was gonna go to yale that year and he
ends up not going to yale he kind of uh
he was like a good student but he wasn't
like a homebody like he had since now
become and he was like that for four or
seven years and so he basically locked
himself in his room because he was
having digestive problems he was
embarrassed because his teeth was all
[__] up and he just felt horrible for
years and years it's not like there was
like they didn't like do surgery on this
and they didn't have like amazing pain
pills for you so he just had to suffer
and in that time he started reading a
lot and he actually like read a book on
bicycles and he got really interested in
bicycles at the time someone bought him
like a toy plane that was kind of like a
kite but it was like a plane and he
started getting really fascinated with
mechanics and fascinated with planes and
once he once he healed he decided i'm
gonna this is gonna be my life this is
what i'm going to do is instead of going
to yale like i was going to do him
become a doctor his i believe his father
was the doctor he goes i'm going to
study mechanics and i'm going to create
a bicycle shop and then from a bicycle
shop he says i want to create a glider
and then eventually i'm going to create
a plane and it all started
with getting hit in the face and it like
like with a debilitating hit in the face
and he thought that his life was over
and i love stories where you think it's
all over
you have so much uh uh adversity in
front of you and that totally shifts
the outcome i had that one time when i
got fired from a job when i moved out
here i had nothing i was like i don't
know what's gonna happen so i ended up
starting my first company but i love
that story and i wanted to bring that up
because
i love when when bad things happen and
and i've gone through it enough times
that i'm like don't worry this bad thing
well
right it might lead to something really
amazing have you ever had something like
that where it led to something where
you're like my life's over
well okay you know not the wall not
wilbur wright level so first i have a
few questions about the world right so
what's the other brother so if wilbur's
the smart brother who overcame you know
this debilitating smack in the mouth
what's the other brother story
um well i'm only halfway through the
book but they they get along they get
along quite well the younger brother's a
little bit more gregarious and a little
bit more outgoing and so wilbur is the
calculating one orville's the one who
says um hey all right that's a great
idea let's go do it let's go so they
find out that there's this place and
here's another amazing part of the story
so they just talk to friends they talk
to officials they go where is there a
place that has a lot of open land that's
windy and it gets they talk to the for
some reason i don't know why at the time
but the postmaster knew of a good place
and that postmaster connected them to
another postmaster in kitty hawk which
was
dayton to kitty hawk i don't know the
exact exact distance but without a car
it's a massive trek and the boat
brothers are like you know screw it
let's do it so they go out there and
they knock on doors and they find
someone to house them and let them camp
on their land for four weeks at a time
while they test their stuff and it was
so like this is why i love america the
postmaster of kitty hawk was like yeah
you know this whole flight thing i don't
think it's gonna work but like i give
you my thumbs up go out and do it no one
will bother you we got you if anyone
bothers you bothers you holler at us
there was so little bureaucracy i loved
it but uh orville uh was more a little
bit more outgoing and pushed wilbur who
was the more calculating brother and you
said from the beginning because i knew
they had a bicycle shop but that you're
saying from the beginning you said i'm
going to do bicycle then eventually i'm
going to make a plane or did that just
happen it's like you know um toby from
shopify creates
creates a snowboard shop online for his
snowboard company and then creates
shopify but he didn't think to himself
first i'm going to do this then i'm
going to build a platform that will have
millions of stores on it it just sort of
happened that way so which one was it
was it was it a master plan or was it
uh you know what progressive ambition
it was progressive ambition so basically
he saw this plane his toy glider that he
had and he always thought that that was
interesting and but he just kind of let
it sit in the back of his brain and then
he got into bicycles first he started a
a pressing prince a pressing a print
press where he made his own newspaper
and then he's like this is kind of cool
but they learned about bicycles and like
this new cycle technology is amazing we
gotta get into that and again start
getting that and he's like you know what
the key to riding a bike is the the
that's how you balance and he started
staring at birds and he started looking
at this old glider that he had and like
man that balance is the same thing like
that's so important i bet we can
translate that to this you know this
dream i've always had of flying i bet
you it's actually quite similar and so
they just they they they kind of carried
it over
and uh and i think there was like a
bunch of other teams that were way
better funded working on this at the
same time and i think they just beat the
other teams to manned flight by like
four months or something very a very
thin margin where they go down in
history and nobody remembers the second
crew that made it is that right
well i'm not that far along but
throughout the book now they have guys
saying hey i'm friends with andrew
carnegie i can get you guys some money
do you want some funding we can get you
we can get you about 200 000 a year
which is probably like two or three
million now and they go no no our cycle
shop is making enough profits we can we
can afford it which they really like
they they kind of could afford it like
as in barely but they would they would
they would go to kitty hawk and they
would um
they'd go to kitty hawk and they would
find places to crash and and and so it
wasn't like they were rich
um by the way if you like stories like
this we may have something coming down
the pipe
even left we'll announce later yeah okay
so i'm excited about that so uh okay
have i had stories like this um
you know i probably have and i probably
need to go dig it up that's one thing
i've learned especially from story
worthy one of the things in story worthy
is he does he he's not just telling you
how to tell a great story like he does
that right there's mechanics about what
makes a great story and he talks about
what is the beginning supposed to look
like what is the end supposed to look
like how do you raise stakes in a in a
story that sort of thing but the other
thing the main point i think the guy's
trying to get across and story worthy is
that we we all think that like our
day-to-day life doesn't have stories but
once you start looking you'll find
stories everywhere and it gives you
these exercises to do to find stories
from your past there's like this
exercise called first last best worst
and i do this in my course i don't teach
the course anymore but like in my power
writing course i help people come up
with ideas of what to write about and i
use this exercise and it's it's killer
you could take anything so like we'll
just play the game real quick we're
gonna do it with uh
jobs okay so topic is jobs or career
right so give me the first job you ever
had
i worked in a bakery sweeping floors
okay great uh give me the last meaning
most recent job you ever had and that's
probably you know the hustle or maybe
this podcast i was the ceo and owner of
a media company called the hustle right
then it's uh
give me worst so let's go what was the
worst job you ever had
the worst job i ever had was
um
cold calling people in college to sell
seo services out of the yellow pages
there you go all right and then you have
best what was the best job you ever had
the best job i ever had was co-hosting
this podcast all right there we go it's
and then there's another one called
weirdest uh that i added in that's not
story worthy but i added weirdest
because i found that this gives this
gives a lot of good stories out of it so
what's the weirdest job you ever had
that might be the hot dog stand
no i was a skateboard instructor at the
ymca when i was 15.
i learned something new every day about
you all right so so you could do that so
that that gives you a bunch of stuff
that you're like oh if you show that to
somebody else it'd be like what like
what you know like skateboard how did
that come about or how did like how much
money does that make or how did you get
the idea or what's the hardest part
about doing that or what's the what's a
day in like oh you scooped ice cream at
coldstone like
dude like what do i need to know about
cold stone ice cream that you know only
you know because you were there every
day making it and so it's this great way
to generate a bunch of stories so that's
like one of those exercises he has
another one which is like you look for a
five second moment in your day you just
try to jot down at the end of the night
what would have been my story of the day
if today is the last day of my life or
whatever today was the only day of my
life what would have been the story of
the day and you just looked for a
five-second moment
everyday stories i think he called right
and so yeah it's a good book
so i i think everybody myself included
probably has their version of a wilbur
moment it might not be that you
literally got punched in the face it
might be that you like you said got
fired somebody you know slammed you in a
meeting and told you you know
you're you're a dumb ass so this will
never work or um you know whatever you
got rejected in some way you've tried
and spectacularly failed in some way you
publicly failed in some way
and um
the other thing that came to mind when
you tell me this is my brother-in-law
who's come on the show before it's a
crazy man brother aaron he's a crazy man
we gotta have him back on he basically
just goes down rabbit holes and internet
conspiracies and things like that
so
he has this story that he tells
and i'm gonna half tell the story right
now i'll do the fast forward version so
he's like
i was in college i was just having a
great time kind of like 50-year senior
type of [__]
and um
i think maybe he was in grad school
actually for this and he doesn't really
care about his grades he's just partying
he's playing basketball all day he does
he really doesn't care about his grades
and he finds out that and he's taking
out a bunch of loans and he finds out
that you know his gpa his first semester
sucks
and um there's something happen where
like he had one semester left
and
in order to graduate
he needed and not like have to pay a
whole bunch of extra money uh for his
loans because he didn't graduate or
whatever he needed to essentially get a
4.0 gpa so he needed to go from like a
2.1 to like he needed to graduate with a
three point something or i don't know
what the numbers were but basically his
first year gpa was so bad that he needed
an absolute perfect gpa in order to
graduate and not be like 50 000 in the
hole and for somebody who grew up like
on food stamps like 50 000 was like an
insurmountable hole at the time he
didn't want to be in that hole he wanted
to graduate and he was dating my sister
and my sister was like yo you can't just
be like a broke joke who's like not
graduating in mountains of debt so he's
like i'm gonna lose my girl i'm gonna
like oh all this money it's all crashing
down and so he's like okay you know what
i'm gonna do this and so it's like in
the story-worthy format it's like you
have a hero who has an um
intent an obstacle so he has an intent
he has to do this if he doesn't do this
what happens loses the girl of his
dreams is in a mountain of debt will
never recover um you know like basically
has to drop out doesn't finish his
degree and if if he does that whatever
happens those are the stakes and so then
he tells the story and when he's telling
the story he's like there's all these
like additional obstacles that come it's
like
he actually like starts to study super
hard and he's not like
you know he's not like the smartest
smartest guy who it just oh if he tried
a little bit he'd get an a he needs to
get an a plus
uh like he has to get a 97 to 100. if he
doesn't get that he he flunks out of the
program
and he starts studying he actually gets
his first test he gets like a 98
and the teacher calls him into the
office and is basically like you cheated
he's like no i swear he's like dude you
were a f f student and you're g you want
me to believe you have an a plus here no
way you cheated you you know whatever
and so he gets obstacle after obstacle
and then they change the rules or
something so at first he needed an a
which is like a 95 and up then they
changed the rules on the on the gpa
system he now needed an a plus in every
single subject where it's like he needed
a 98 99 or 100 and he's like oh my god
and every day every time you hit one of
these obstacles he just feels like he
can't do it and he just the way he tells
the story he just keeps repeating goes
but then i dug deeper and he just keeps
going he's like i hit rock bottom but
then i dug deeper and he just keeps
saying this over and over and by the
first time he says it you know it has
some effect second time he says it's
losing its effect third time you're
laughing
by the 17th time because by the way he's
telling the story not of him telling the
story now it's
he went to a job interview with nasa and
nasa was like yo you're not an engineer
like why would we give you this job and
he told that he tells the story he's
like because i know my limits and every
other kid you have coming in here is
from a good family who's got good grades
their whole life they don't know what
they're made of
i tested myself i know what i'm made of
i dug deeper when i hit rock bottom when
i couldn't do more i went further and he
just keeps going and he tells us
he got the job and he and when he tells
the story just makes everybody laugh and
i when i heard that story not only does
it make me laugh it made me think
everybody deserves to have a story like
this and if you don't then when you're
in a shitty time just think to yourself
this is my dig deeper story okay pile on
the obstacles because you know what i
need it for this story to be great in
the end
yeah he's uh i've hung out with him a
bit that guy is crazy and i enjoy
i enjoy that story can i tell you um
can i tell you about something that's
going on on twitter that i find to be
incredibly fascinating yeah so right now
i've singled out four people
but there's probably 12 of them or maybe
24 of them so there's something very
weird going on about
real estate twitter okay and i just and
i contacted three of them and i posted
all my notes you see my notes on there
yep i see them i know all these i just
okay i'm actually meeting up with one of
them tonight uh strip mall the strip
mall guy so
for the listeners
basically like twitter is experiencing
some crazy stuff right now and obviously
me and sean are deep in one particular
niche but i have a feeling that that
niche is quite large and that niche is
like techy startupy people tweeting
stuff and also there's like a big
overlap with crypto and nft stuff and
that's even probably much larger and
then next to that is like robin hood and
stocks and fin they call what they call
it fin twin and that's probably even the
biggest but there's this new subset of
people that i'm seeing and i think it's
new and
it's nowhere near the biggest there's
like marketing twitter there's like
teacher twitter there's like every
profession has like oh i mean like some
culture i mean like some of the
i met some of the bigger uh i meant the
biggest of the the ones i had mentioned
uh okay and yeah yeah and and keep in
mind that like if we're looking at a
piece of the pie
the everything i just mentioned is like
maybe like it's like it's like a like a
maybe like a 15 of the pie so it's like
not big but if you're listening to this
you are likely part of that and so
there's a very new and emerging part of
that pie and is these guys who are
constantly tweeting about boring real
estate stuff and
as as a whole the leaders are [__]
crushing it it is some of the most
not boring as in sam's judgment boring
as in that's actually their positioning
is like oh you guys talking about all
this fancy [__] i just do boring stuff
and i make a bunch of money that's
actually their brand that they want to
bring in
so that i think at least i think it's
intentional i don't think they're trying
to be boring i think they're trying to
say hey boring businesses print money
and there's like this counter culture
counterculture appeal to it in the same
way that some people are like oh vc it's
all just a big waste of money and you
know it's a bunch of you know it's a
fool's race i actually bootstrap and i
make profits i have my profitability and
they use that as their badge of honor
but the reason why i want to bring this
up now is because we are in the early
stages or maybe in the middle we're
right in the thick of it it's not huge
huge yet but we're seeing something
happen here and i want to call it out
because i think it's very fascinating to
watch this and so here's there's
actually four guys i only talked to
three of them ahead of time but i'm
friends with the fourth one so i can
kind of like riff off them a little bit
but there's four guys that i went and
dm'd and the first there's a guy named
strip mall guy uh his handle is strip
mall guy or or but his name is trent and
people call him strip mall trent
and so we're gonna talk about him the
second guy we're gonna talk about is a
guy named moses kagan moses kagan uh so
strip mall guy buys strip malls and it's
hilarious his twitter the second guy is
moses kagan he buys multi-family in la
the third is keith wasserman who is one
of your third fifth eighth guest on the
podcast and he does multi-family and
then the fourth guy is this guy who
we're both great friends with nick huber
who i'm an investor of and he buys
storage units and he's made it so
popular that he gets mocked regularly
because of it and so i want to tell you
a little bit about each guy i will go
really quick so strip mall guy so fax so
he has 500 million dollars in assets
under management his twitter is
anonymous um i'm actually about to go go
for he's actually staying down the
street for me i'm gonna go hang out with
him uh right after this he's 41 years
old he uh uses none of his own money so
99.9 percent is other people's money and
he has bought roughly 500 million
dollars worth of strip malls and what he
does is um
he finds strip malls that he thinks are
undervalued and he just fixes them up
and he either holds them or flips them
and his the reason why he thinks this is
a huge deal is because the the there's a
huge lack of uh data in this business so
the rents that people are paying versus
what the market rent is like it's really
hard to know if if you're if you're
charging your attendance market rate and
for some reason that's incredibly
challenging and he goes that's where the
opportunity is so i just work really
hard and i knock on doors to find out
what everyone's paying in rent and i
come up with uh and then i find a strip
mall where they're underpaying and i buy
it and i increase rent and i fix it up a
little bit so anyway that's kind of
interesting and so he told me that he
pays himself or he personally cash flows
three million dollars a year from this
kind of interesting and he does it with
a team of four
that's pretty fascinating isn't it right
yeah of course so is he a syndicate or
it's a fun i think it sounds like it's
indicator
i don't know i actually i don't know um
i think a fun but he has like family
offices behind him so i guess if he's a
syndicate that means he just does a deal
by deal versus having a fundraiser
deploy um
i i yeah i don't actually know um kind
of fascinating the second guy
is um and he's in this guy strip mall
trent i believe he just started when did
he start uh like his mother sounds like
less than a year old and i dm'd him and
i was like uh oh by the way he he told
me actually i had asked him he said deal
my deal basis um
and i think he's now gonna now gonna
raise the fund he's like it's insane how
many people are dming me about investing
in my deals and stuff like that he's
like my twitter account is an anonymous
i'm an anonymous cartoon character i
might you know i could be anything he's
like you know i am the real deal but
like they don't know that that's crazy
that how much how much opportunity there
is on twitter for somebody who's vocal
in their space
and then um and he was actually he's
like should i you know tell my friends
about who i am like my account or
whatever and i told him i said keep it
super super tight to the vest uh it will
get out if you if you if even if you
everybody you tell
you trust them they trust three people
they trust three people and like by the
by you know three hops later the word is
out and so uh so i told him i said don't
tell me who you are just just uh stay
anonymous keep doing what you're doing
it's gonna get really big
and i agree and it's one of the reasons
why it's interesting there's another
there's a guy uh who doesn't think he's
22 000 followers now i bet you he's at
100 in less than six months this guy's
going to be big and uh there's another
guy who runs this
[Music]
newsletter called petition where he
talks about um
companies that are going bankrupt and
who can buy them and he runs that all
anonymously and one time he called me
and asked for advice and i sent him a
zoom link and he screwed up and he put
his name in the thing and i go bro i
just saw it turn it off and i like
deleted it from my brain so i don't
actually remember his name but i talked
to him on the phone uh a regular basis
but i'm like just you know i still don't
remember your name so okay so you just
said that this guy tr uh was able to
raise money or is it being offered let's
go to the second guy his name is moses
kagan he currently has 200 million
dollars through au on under uh
management and he's deployed 30 million
dollars of uh sorry he's had 40 million
dollars come from twitter so this guy
started tweeting about his deals he got
40 million
of his twitter followers they came up
with 40 million dollars to invest in his
fun he said one guy gave him 20 million
and he found it through twitter is that
nuts we have a friend
who put a couple million bucks into his
thing
yeah i know and i i talked about him and
did he say that he's happy with it
uh i think it's early so i i think it's
probably too early to say but he
recommended it to me he's like i think
he should do one of these guys deal so
that means he kicked the tires and was
like
yeah i think it's worth you know like
this guy seems to be smart uh seems to
know what he's doing so so i think that
was you know trusted enough
i flew down and i met up with him i
thought he was great and then
the third one is keith wasserman so
keith currently has close to two billion
dollars in assets under management for
for his real estate deal and he said um
that uh uh he's so he's got a thousand a
thousand investors he said and uh
twitter 5xed his his uh his fund so
that's pretty nuts and then the last one
nick huber is who's a good friend of
both of ours i came became friends with
him through twitter basically i was
doing a live video and he popped in and
i just became friends with him and now
we're like i'm gonna go visit him in his
house and hang out with them and we um i
invested 100 both have that redneck
energy to you you guys both you know you
just want to be out in the sun all day
get sunburned while you're like hunting
fishing golfing and shooting something
at the same time like if i could just
put those four objects one on each limb
you'd be a happy person put a rifle on
the hand a fishing pole on your toes
you know that's what you guys want both
of you you're like i love you he texts
us he's smoking a cigar it's tuesday at
1 p.m he's like kids are running around
his giant like i don't know farm or
wherever he wherever the hell he lives
he's got a bunch of anchorage and he's
just like yeah life is good we're going
we're going to go white water rafting in
like you know my backyard right now
he's awesome i i invested in it and uh
the returns have been pretty good and
anyway i thought it was crazy
fascinating and so i'm going to give
everyone a take away here's my opinion
here's an easy one where this can be
made so there's a guy
already who's doing this with vending
machines we talked about him his name
was quinn miller i think he's doing
pretty good um but there's another one
that i think that this could be done so
click the link uh you see where it says
car wash advisory.com
yes
okay so i found this website um and
basically what they do is if you go to
carwashadvisory.com and then you click
buying and then you can see car washes
for sale you can look at how much car
washes are selling for and
i'm honestly shocked at how expensive
these are you can see what their eba
does you can see what their profit or
what their profit with their revenue you
can see all types of stuff um and it's
pretty fascinating i think because this
is so interesting i think that there's a
world where someone could get into this
business and start tweeting about it
constantly and just tweet publicly
our youtube people put the put the
website if it put this like put the
website go to buy and put that on the uh
on the screen right now like
this is how you know this is a great
website because all the listings that
are sold it goes it just has this huge
stamp it says sold and then there's
balloon like these clip art balloons all
over the listing
that's that's how i know that this thing
is amazing uh it's like you know when
you see somebody who's like you know
driving a fancy car and they get out and
they have like total like dad wardrobe
it's like yeah this person's
it's the opposite of the person who's
really slick getting out and you're like
ah did they lease this thing and is this
is this a rental like you know they're
doing it for the image versus when the
image is so bad but the money is so high
it's like oh yeah that's where there's
dumb money it's great yes and i think
that you could do this so nick's got a
thing on this guy's doing strip malls uh
moses and keith are doing multi-family
nick's got storage um
there could be there's this guy quinn's
got vending there's a there's room for
car wash i think i think that that was
that you were going somewhere else i
think and maybe this is just me probably
you too right now which is like
once you get a little bit of money
it's like
you go get your phd in tax avoidance and
i think it's crazy that nobody has just
taken the throne here of saying
i'm gonna talk all day
about these little financial hack
strategies for high net worth people
around um
you know just either examples or
strategies or loopholes or little did
you know about you can go into an
opportunity zone and then you can roll
that through a 1031 over here and then
you could backdoor the backdoor ira and
then you can do a super roth it's like
you know like whatever i'm just making
up terms but
i think everything you said made sense
unfortunately
i'm pretty sure it didn't but there's
somebody who should be owning that like
there's one guy his name is mitchell
something mitchell
baldrige i don't know like it's one of
those names i've never said out loud i
just see him on twitter all the time he
kind of does this it's basically a cpu
wait is he does he look like a really
really white dude like a grown-up dennis
the menace
yes exactly mitchell baldwin yeah
21 000 followers i did a call with him
because i was thinking about you know
should i use him for my stuff um and
it's like yeah he's a texas cpa focused
on family and helping high net worth 30
to 500 million investors and business
owners preserve and grow their wealth
and then it's like you know this is not
financial advice um
but basically i just think that there is
such a lack of information last night i
was like
i do this thing because my daughter's
bedtime schedule is like all screwed up
it's like takes forever to put her to
bed now um and like you know there's
probably some way to like shorten that
but my hack is always like how do i just
have more fun doing this rather than try
to make it more efficient and so my hack
to have it more fun is headphones in
while i'm like putting her to bed and i
learned something so like um you know
either audiobook or listen to a really
good talk or right now my shtick is like
this week is crypto week but besides
that i've been doing
tax text learning so you know like what
are the different things that people do
in order to
generate a lot of income and pay minimal
tax
and it's so hard to find somebody who's
good at this on youtube like there's
definitely stuff out there but it's like
i don't know how to describe it it's
like dollar store [__] it's like
yeah it's kind of cheap it's kind of
tacky it's like way too surface level
um
and it's like too
it's like you know it'll be like did you
know there's a 401k it's like okay i
need more than that
but you know like still delivered to me
in a way that's like simple and
understandable and like walks me through
cases like yeah i have a client who's
you know made a bunch of money through
selling a company and so then we started
buying real estate and here's the type
of real estate we bought and here's how
we managed it and here's what we did
with the depreciation to offset these
things right like i want more and so i
feel like tax is one of those boring
topics that's a great one get super big
with like this now the incentive is kind
of not there in that it's a service
based business more so than
you know these real estate guys because
they just want a bunch of investors to
pile in so they can go buy bigger and
bigger deals yeah but look like who
doesn't want more customers yeah yeah
exactly or better and better customers i
so the to wrap this up the more the
story is there's some amazing people out
here particularly in this real estate
niche but i think that you can do this
for many things there's loads of
services loads of like real estate
things i mean we're talking about
vending machines car washes uh taxes and
these these guys are making in like i
guess like in order to be good at that
i'm gonna disrespect these folks a
little bit but like it doesn't seem like
you have to be that good to be good at
it you know what i mean like if you just
do if you're just pretty good and and
you're consistently at least pretty good
and you do it for 30 years you can be a
[__] winner and what they're doing is
they're making it really hard to lose by
getting this massive audience and
creating this incredibly interesting
content around typically boring stuff
and so everyone who has money is like oh
can i give you some more can i give you
some money please so anyway i think
that's interesting it's and it's
happening right now and so that's why i
wanted to call this out this is not
something that we i don't want to look
back i want to say look this is
happening it's kind of neat yeah
basically the fewer the people the less
common it is uh for people in your
industry to be
blogging or tweeting or podcasting the
more of an opportunity there is for you
to go do it there is an insatiable
appetite for this stuff and if your
industry is sort of backwards slow it's
private behind closed doors bigger
opportunity for you than it is for guys
like us because in our industry
everybody's doing it so it's less
it's less cool it's less opportunities
for just to be the
30 000th tech person to tweet their tech
views you know
so all right i'm gonna let you lead
because you actually have a ton of good
stuff and i kind of dominated a lot of
the time
okay so i want to talk about this thing
i've been doing that this week um called
crypto week so okay what dude i almost
got i almost got so mad at you when i
saw that tweet because you go i told bad
kids i was like sean we only have one
meeting this week it's only 10 minutes
please i hope you don't showed up i
showed up
but i did tell i did tell ben and i tell
that i said hey no meetings this week so
i did one with you for our youtube
channel because that's ten minutes
it was ten minutes it was great um shout
out to essie and then it was
at this podcast this is the only two
commitments i have on the calendar this
week good all right thank you
so
besides that i cleared everything off
and i didn't just clear the calendar of
meetings i just said
i'm not working on my other [__]
e-commerce business not doing it this
week and ironic things like having its
best week ever but like i basically just
told our ad guy i said hey i'm on
vacation now am i actually on vacation
no i'm sitting in my garage
18 hours a day
neck deep in crypto and uh why is it so
basically are you are you just sitting
with your phone
right now
no is that what you're doing because
like i met whenever i do these weeks
which i do them as well i i'm just like
surrounded by books reading but are you
really you really just leaned over on
your chair with your phone in front of
you and you're just like drinking milk
laptop my laptop drinking milk exactly
i'm on that i'm on that edison diet
right now i'm just drinking milk and i'm
inventing the future so um
so what i think is uh this is kind of
amazing so i had read that bill gates
does this uh like once one week out of
the year he calls it his think week or
his reading week or something like that
where he's just like throughout the year
he gets interested in certain topics but
he doesn't he's so busy that he doesn't
get to go as deep on that topic as he
would otherwise want to like he's got
more curiosity than he has time in the
moment and so what he does is he carves
out this one week a year and then it's
let's say that that he's all about
crispr right let's say that that's what
he was really interested in
and uh and by the way for all the people
who are like oh bill gates he's trying
to like [__] poison everybody it's
like okay yeah step aside please um
basically he
he takes his all his books on crisper
and he goes to a cabin he doesn't take
his wife and he doesn't take his kids
and he locks himself in the cabin and he
just reads he just immerses himself in
that thing and he comes out the other
side with a greater understanding of
this topic that he was curious about
so i wanted to do this for crypto now
i'm like i'm not like a noob at crypto
right like you know we've been
talking about it on this podcast
i i've you know been buying and owning
assets since i don't know 2014 or
something like that and so like it's not
like this is like a completely new
subject but it was wow this space is
evolving so fast and there are so many
toys that i haven't got to play with i'm
gonna do this and so um
and i can't tell you how fun this has
been i i want to tell you why but like
that's just the highlights the intro
where do you want me to go with this
well uh for so i don't want to talk too
much about this concept of doing a
crypto or book reading week because it's
so i i'm totally on board with it
everyone should do it so i don't even
want to talk have you ever done
something like this
um
not lately not in the past couple years
but i have before so i've done it with
like copywriting i'm like i'm gonna
learn everything yeah it's very you can
you can learn so much you have to shut
down slack facebook twitter and just not
look at anything
and so i'm gonna give you a few things
that i've observed during this so first
about doing one of these weeks
it fits my fits the like framework of
how i see the world which is that that
work like a lion not like a cow and that
this is a sprint week and it's a sprint
week around learning but it's a sprint
week nonetheless it's like a lion when
they find their prey and they want to go
sprint uh at it um it's like a mini
vacation or a mini retirement in a way
it's like what would i do if i really
wasn't working actively on anything well
i would just be kind of learning and you
know i'd be like interested in all these
things because i had all this free time
well i gave myself a mini shot of that
for a week uh it reduces fomo like crazy
because there was always this itch this
this
this uh this aching feeling like i'm
missing out on all this opportunity
because i'm busy with you know my good
projects that i like but like i just
don't have time to even know what i
don't know and so this reduces fomo and
last thing is learning by immersion so
i'm not just the only one doing it my
team which is ben and andre i cleared
off their whole calendar too and i said
don't do any of your normal things
you're doing andre
andre andre new guy he took my power
writing course dude andre's story is
[__] nuts can i tell you this i
didn't tell you about this guy he
created this website let me actually
find uh go to go to uh sup shawn.com so
sup
and then my name shawn.com and just read
this for a second hi sean i'm andre
okay
so this guy made this website he sent it
to me and you go it's called sup
shawn.com so i'm curious and he says hey
sean i'm andre i'm a future student in
your power writing course i built the
biggest large biggest student startup
conference in canada uh blah blah blah
oh by the way i just recovered from
being wheelchair slash bedbound for two
years check out my blog post for stories
about why i made this site for you i'm
not looking to grab a copy of your chat
i love you i like the hustle of this
website i just have one quick question i
want your help with and then he has like
he stole like the design off my website
and he just put a bunch of fake quotes
of people being like you're a legend wow
like quote wow sean when seeing this
website
um and then he's talked about what he's
working on now and then he has a
question and he's like
if you were me you've just been strapped
to your bed for a couple years and
you're now starting your career how
would that how would you change your
approach to life and work some context i
had this thing of a jig for five years
and i've just got over it and i feel
like i've been given a second life by
the way the fact that he didn't like go
into a sob story and explain yeah
just calling it a thingamajig just told
me yo i'm on your level of like
i'm not looking for your sympathy but
this is true and i'm just explaining to
you this situation i'm in uh so so mad
respect for the way he did that he goes
i just want to maximize every year blah
blah blah
you know blah blah blah and so anyways
he uh he got me to reply and he took my
course he was great then he sent me this
video after my course like yo here's
three things you should be doing better
in your next cohort like really loved it
here's three three ways where i would
make this better i just hired him i was
like come do that and then he came and
he did that for me and now i'm like he's
brought such good energy where like
literally every day he's like
just
he's on one dude he's never in a bad
mood he's always in a good mood and it's
amazing how far enthusiasm and having
like positive vibes goes as far as like
my books at least and so uh that's
always important but i brought him up
and he's working on your course so he
did my course but now i like the course
was like a smash success last month and
i was like
i'm kind of bored of this let's go do
some other [__] so like uh he's not
doing that right now but he's helping me
with with other [__] so this crypto week
thing uh anyways we're all doing it so a
couple things that i've learned so
i'm a big believer in learning by doing
and so my attitude for this week was
what are i thought of it like disney
world i was like okay there's all the
and if you go to disney world it's like
you can go to the magic kingdom you can
go to like whatever the harry potter
land you can go over here to this other
area so i started mapping out the
different worlds there's like the nft
world there's like defy world there's
like kind of like security world i need
to learn how to i got kind of like a
like a good amount of this stuff like i
wanna what are the best practices for
securing this and i've been putting off
uh okay you know what's better than what
i'm currently doing um and so i just
mapped out all these different areas i'm
curious about and that we started diving
in one day on each just going as deep as
we can uh with each one
but are you are you like messaging your
team throughout the day like let's
everyone let's sit for three hours and
read this and we'll come back and talk
basically so it's like we're just
sharing stuff in slack and then we do
these like slack has that huddle feature
now which is like really dope yeah it's
like a quick little discord chat
basically so we'll huddle up and we'll
be like um we we kind of set out at the
beginning which was
dude what would i want but what i would
want is when i wanted to spend a week
going deep into crypto and get a real
understanding i wish somebody just had
this
had a product like this where i could
just
it's not a course it's not like a vlog
it's like uh the best way i've learned
about crypto has been furcon my smart
friend
basically who knows this [__] inside and
out
he just sits me down on a zoom call and
he screen cheers he's like all right so
like do you have meta mask and i'm like
uh do i maybe i feel like i might have
made one once he's like okay well like
here's what that is it's this wallet it
lives in your browser it's how you do
[__] in the crypto world so like let's
get your set up and like by the way
don't fall for these scams like here's
the smart way to do it and so then i
click it click it and i'm like hey this
says this he's like yeah that's normal
go ahead and he just holds my hand and
sort of teaches me like he's like okay
have you ever um taken out a default
loan i'm like no why would i do that
he's like well you know let's say you
wanted to not sell your crypto but you
want to go buy some [__] in the real
world and the banks don't recognize it
so let's go take out a loan for like
super low percent rate and let me show
you how you do that you're going to go
to compound.finance and then you're
going to put your ethe in using that
wallet we just made and now you're going
to take a loan and let's take that loan
let's go do something with it and so
he's walked me through step by step and
so i'm like i want to do that with all
the new areas of crypto and then
secondly when i was talking to the guys
yesterday i was like
dude the way we are learning this by
having our hand held where we like have
trust and confidence that we're doing
the right things we should just make
this the next course which is like it's
not really like a course it's like a
zoom call you join and it takes you on a
tour through disneyland it's like here's
all the attractions
and like i'm not just going to tell you
about them like actually like
you're first editing
who's leading you right now is leading
me so i do it oh so he's and he's when
he gets stuck yeah when i get stuck i
say hey can you show us like
like liquidity pools i heard you saying
you make money in this i don't really
understand what's the point of this
liquidity pool and like how do i
actually do this and like
what do i do to do this in a way like
tell me the pros and cons and the risks
so i can make a smart decision on
whether i want to do this in the future
but like let's do my first liquidity
pool trade together and then like i have
my dashboard of how much i'm making off
this right or like oh yeah you um you
know you you have this nft
great like i want to display that how do
i do that how do i secure this how do i
store this safely great how do i mint
one you know like all the different like
questions that i have if i can't figure
it out myself by doing i call him in and
he kind of like shows me he screen
shares and shows me what to do step by
step so what are the learnings so crypto
week what are like the top one to five
learnings that you have so far
so one big learning is like
dude this is evolving so fast it's like
it's like if you you know when you go by
a club and you kind of hear the music
faintly from the outside you're like um
huh like you hear this little hum
like little you hear the bass from the
outside but it's not that loud you walk
by you go on to your you know your cafe
or your bus stop wherever you're going
you leave
it's like i swung open the door and
there's a full underground rave going on
and everybody's having you know this
crazy time and and now that i'm in it
i'm like wow the energy has really
picked up last time i was here was like
you know a year ago and i was kind of on
the outside now i'm on the inside i'm
seeing what's really going on how crazy
this energy is what does that translate
to
well there's a whole bunch of like
developer tools because anytime i see
something cool that i'm using i'm like
can i invest in this company and so like
the way that during during the internet
explosion you had companies like twilio
or pagerduty or you know like all these
just like basic infrastructure stripe
it's like oh yeah people need to take
payments people need to be able to send
notifications send sms's every every
product that's on the internet that's
going to build at the internet is going
to eventually want to do these things
they're going to want to have cloud
hosting and so i'm finding the
equivalent of cloud hosting and twilio
and all that stuff these dev tools that
are in in what's called web 3 or the
crypto world and i'm like dude i need to
be investing in these because if crypto
is going to be a thing then these are
these infrastructure companies
just like they did great in the in the
internet age they're going to do great
in the crypto age so that's the first
what else what else have you learned
so like then it's like okay how do you
actually
you know nfts it's kind of this thing
that like i thought it was interesting i
owned a couple but like it also seemed a
little bit nuts and like why are people
doing this are they all just like
trying to make a quick buck and they're
just you know you know doing some crazy
[__] or is this actually the new art and
i'm missing
today i'm laughing at it and then three
years from now i'm gonna be the one
pimping it out because like now i aha
get it uh you know the same way i was
with bitcoin early on where i was like
that's kind of weird don't really get it
move on and three years later i'm like
oh this is the you know jesus christ our
lord and savior and so um so what i've
learned is like
i've been actually using the tools so
like check this out go to go to a site
called rarity.tools
[Music]
so i've been using this as i've been
looking at which nfts i wanted to
collect and buy i gave myself a quarter
million dollar budget for this week to
to go play in crypto world and some of
that's used
some of that's used on buying nfts and i
haven't used most of it yet i've only
bought a couple things um
but but basically that's my like
learning budget if i want to do
something i can do up to that amount and
look at the similar web traffic on
rarity.tools
holy [__]
holy [__] that that like that it's like
a water slide
yeah exactly april it's like at zero
essentially uh you know it's like a
convert ramp it's like under under half
a million uh uniques and then you know
july just under a million august it's
now at three and a half million it's
just hockey sticking up and what is this
this is just like what we talk about
like this is a picks and shovels
business so anytime there's a gold rush
you can either go try to find the gold
meaning go find the best nft and oh you
bought a crypto punk and now it's worth
seven million dollars okay that's one
way you found a nugget of gold or this
is a great picks and shovels business
which is like hey a bunch of people are
interested in nfts cool we will make a
site that helps you figure out the
rarity of different nfts it helps you
find underpriced assets that are you
know the price is good given the rarity
and so um so i think this is a great
example of like of a picks and shovels
website for the crypto world so i've
found a bunch of these types of tools as
well and then met a bunch of the people
behind it and so uh you know like one
guy who's behind one of these tools is
like dude i'm a big fan of the show like
my story's nuts at 15 or 16 i entered an
online scrabble tournament that was like
a million dollar tournament and i just
wrote a bot for me back then that nobody
else they didn't know how to outlaw this
so i won the tournament like i won the
million dollar scrabble tournament using
a bot at age 15 and then at age 17 i did
this and i just 21 i did this and then
now i have this discord with 90 000
people in it called rarity sniper and
it's all about finding like
nfts that are undervalued and i have
like 90 000 people in this discord
server and i'm like you're finding all
these people and the biggest lesson i've
seen is it's a whole different
demographic like these are new rich
people the the winners and the builders
like the people who are going to be the
mark zuckerbergs and the larry pages and
the brian chesky's like
it's not the it's not the people we all
know that are like twitter famous that
are making it big in the crypto world
it's a whole new set of people and most
of them are like anonymous just icon
accounts and then i'm talking to them
and i'm like dude you're fascinating
you're also like a madman but like wow
this is crazy
what um okay so right now where where do
you stand and uh
you're
okay so i would place you
i think
on the correct side of reasonable but
not exactly so like parts of you are
reasonable like normal person reasonable
other parts of you you're you're a crazy
person so i kind of trust your opinion
on this but not always so try to try to
be try to keep that in mind you want the
reasonable person is that who you want
to talk about reasonable sean or you
want to talk to a rational show
where do you think do you think okay so
what's your take right now on the nft
world are you as bullish as some of
these our friends and uh where what's
your current stance on it
so i was in this like one-hour
conversation with some random ass nft
anonymous guy on twitter in dms and i
was talking to him but by the way just
just these 90 000 person discords and
talking random people that alone is this
that's a phenomenon
right the way that all these people are
like this thing got minted it was called
rookie nft and i like bought a couple it
was real cheap it's like it's just
coming out like 45 minutes before that
something's like hey check this out
you're into sports you'll probably like
this and i did like it was actually a
really smart concept so i bought a bunch
of them right away and again these are
lottery tickets you buy you most likely
you just scratch it you throw it away
and you got nothing and sometimes you
you hit big and so like one of mine that
i bought you know has i gone up 5x in
value already um and you know of my of
one of these nft bets that i made in the
last two days but the and the others are
just like flat like cost of doing
business basically and so
i said look early on i wrote off bitcoin
because i was like i don't get it it's
not this has no intrinsic value it's
imaginary money it was made up by an
anonymous person and like
it's going up and like what happens when
the music stops meaning what happened
you know it's going up
people are buying it because they think
it's going to keep going up
and that seems like a ponzi scheme that
seems like a pyramid scheme that was my
initial like this is 2014 2015 me
thinking i didn't really understand 2013
maybe actually and um and over time as i
got to unders that was just my lack of
understanding over time i started to
understand that actually all the things
we call money
they're all this they all operate the
same way why is this piece of paper
valuable why is this lump of gold
valuable why is this diamond on a tiny
diamond valuable because there's a
social agreement yeah there's a social
agreement and the social agreement
happens because we justify it through
rarity uh right gold is somewhat rare
diamonds are somewhat rare um so
scarcity basically is there um and then
there's like you know some intrinsic
poll or or whatever but really it's a
social agreement
and a lot of the meaning we place on it
comes later
and so i was like i get i i didn't get
that at the time when it came to
cryptocurrencies money i didn't realize
that
actually it's not just a ponzi scheme
that actually the more people who buy in
actually is what it what makes it
valuable so it's not a bubble that's
going to pop it's that the more
believers that you have that's the
stronger the social agreement is and
therefore the thing actually that
actually gives it real value and um and
this appeals to certain people and so
it's going to
it's going to grow in this that social
agreement is going to grow and i think
there's some crazy charts by the way
that show like bitcoin adoption is i
think one of the fastest if not the
fastest adopted technology ever
so i don't want to say the word ever of
all technologies maybe like i don't know
the printing press or like the telephone
was a little bit faster
from what from what i heard i haven't
gone and verified this before i heard it
was faster faster than all those but if
you just look at the internet for sure
it happened so mobile phones and the
internet were probably the two most
recent technologies that took over the
world right and if you look at mobile
phone adoption and and uh and internet
adoption bitcoin is on a faster pace
than both of those and so um so the the
social agreement is what gives
cryptocurrency value and so i was like
but this art thing like dude i remember
cryptokitties in 2017 right for condo
sitting next to me at the office and he
had two kitties and he was breeding them
and he gave me a kitty heat bread and i
was like what the [__] is this and he's
like it's an nft's he was explaining to
me for the first time back in 2017. i
was like oh that's cool but like
and there was this hype i remember one
day
cryptokitties overwhelmed the ethereum
network it was like eighty percent of
all activity on ethereum was just
cryptokitties and andreessen horowitz
put all this money into cryptokitties
and then like a year later cryptokitties
were dead and um it was like the beanie
babies fad but even faster and by the
way that same team who built crypto
kitties they're the ones who built an a
top shot as well um and so so anyways i
was just like who's to say that today
you guys are spending millions of
dollars on crypto punks and millions of
dollars on this board ape yacht club um
who's to say two years from now this is
not crypto kitties all over again
and then a bunch of those believers kind
of gave me a bunch of reasons and what i
realized was it's the same thing it's
the same same idea which is that art has
value because of a social social
agreement a social construct so why is
the mona lisa more valuable than the
next painting of a chick looking
sideways well because we as a society
have over time decided more and more
that the mona lisa is valuable and it's
not doesn't matter what type of paint
was used what size of canvas it doesn't
matter what year it was made like art
can have value based on the social
agreement how many crypto punks are
there
ten thousand
okay so my argument is like
well maybe there was like a few then
yeah could it be valuable in a hundred
years yeah maybe but there's like ah
mona lisa
yeah but you know you say oh how many
you know monets are there how many uh
how many how many paintings did this
artist do it's like in their lifetime
they maybe made a few hundred or
whatever it was and so you know you can
go find any picasso painting and it's
valuable and that's the idea is that
these are like
these are the picasas right it's like
the og stuff i think it's the first nft
project uh ever was was crypto punks and
that's what has it's kind of like story
value uh and now the people who believe
it it's like bitcoin so there's this
great quote that came out that was like
again i don't know if this is true or
this folklore but recently some of the
big finance guys started buying a bunch
of bitcoin and i think it was um
stanley druckenmiller who was on the
podcast with uh trunk
he came he said you know the thing that
turned me around on it was
i thought oh this thing gets pumped up
then it crashes down it's too volatile
isaac and then paul tudor jones who's
this billionaire hedge fund
billionaire hedge fund trader uh one of
the most famous guys from wall street he
called junker miller he goes hey did you
know this that when bitcoin crashed from
its all-time high which was like 17 18
000 down to 3 000 that 86 percent of the
people who held it never sold a single
coin
and he's like wow that's amazing the
people who own this thing they're like
religious zealots about it and he said
well if people are that religious about
it meaning if the social agreement the
social construct is that strong the
belief is that strong that it can
withstand an 80 crash and they don't
liquidate this thing is going to go up
and this thing is going to be like have
long-term value and that's the thing
that i see right so that's the probably
the only area i've changed my mind is
that
i wasn't going to buy crypto punks for
48 but i thought it was just another
crypto kitty that's probably going to go
away and now i'm starting to realize is
that the people who own punks like if
you go to openc right now you go try to
buy crypto punk you can't just none for
sale it's like
these people don't want to sell them
they're like the bitcoin people who are
like
bitcoin's gonna be worth a million
dollars a coin someday
the the crypto punk holders they have
infected each other with this story that
says
this is the original nft this is like
the most valuable art that will ever be
created in crypto world um
this these are going to be worth you
know 10 million each and they've
convinced themselves that that's true
and that because of that there's like no
supply on the market uh and then you
know supply demand will sort of tell you
so you're you're okay so nft's got it
you're not now after you're halfway
through your week of learning your
current stance on on crypto as a whole
i mean i was super bullish before i'm
super bullish now it really wasn't i'm
trying to judge whether this is good or
bad that's not really what this was it
isn't even really i'm trying to
understand it better although that does
come it was just
dude i haven't had time to actually go
use all the different stuff that's been
built like i already owned the
cryptocurrencies i already own the
assets what i didn't do was you know
there's a lot of things built of what
you can do with your ethereum you can
stake it you can trade it you can
blend you can borrow you can buy nfts
you can fractionalize those nfts you can
create a dow which is like this
organization it's like this group but
it's got a wallet there's all these
different things you can do and i knew
of them but i haven't done them and
there's like a lot of value in actually
going
and taking the time to go use the apps
right it's like go use the products and
then form your own opinions on how you
feel about them but for me it was really
isn't even about the opinions it's like
it takes time to actually learn how to
actually go do all this stuff and
if i was 20 today and i'm just you know
my time is worth jack [__] and i have
nothing else to do this is all i'd be
doing and this is how i would become
valuable what i noticed was that like
it's kind of like the people who didn't
really figure out the internet because
they were successful in real estate or
doctors or whatever it's like i don't
want my success to inhibit my own
ability to go play and learn and so
that's what this week was for me
this is i'm i'm like chewing on all this
i got to think about all this this is
nutty to me i your
it's like the way that maybe like maybe
um
maybe like some fitness stuff the way
that it comes to me and i just like
i grab it easily and i enjoy it and i am
obsessed with it that's how you are with
this it's so hard for someone who's not
pre
pre uh
i don't know who's predisposed to this
type of stuff to
like when i hear you talking this stuff
is a great example because
you're athletic so if i say there's a
track nearby you go you go there and you
[__] run on this track in circles and
i'm like oh man that sounds like a
lot of work i don't really want to do
that or if i'm like yeah there's this
knees over toes guy you go by the
program and you spend the next six weeks
trying to do pistol squats on one knee
and then like you're like oh boxing cool
then you go join a boxing gym and you go
sign up for an amateur fight like
i'm doing that in the way that i'm
athletic which is like great yeah like
when i go to when i go to a discord i'm
like i it's like i'm like i'm like a
little autistic going into an ikea i'm
like i just i'm overwhelmed i don't know
what to do i want to clam up i'm
freaking out there's too much
uh all right you want to do want to run
through a few of these things or are we
going to wrap up i have a two i have a
two interest i have two interesting
things i wanted to show you uh okay
let's do this
this is related there's this great
twitter thread i thought i wanted to get
your opinion on it's about levels of
levels of wealth and something we've
talked about on here before but i
thought this guy's take was interesting
so okay this the account is i i i 529
and i read it but i i like your i like
yours he didn't do a very good job of
writing it
uh did he not okay maybe he didn't okay
so his writing wasn't as clear as yours
okay i thought it was pretty good maybe
i'm wrong but anyways i thought the
material was good so this is one of
those anonymous twitter accounts that's
like this guy's clearly wealthy he owns
something crypto punks and he's like
kind of smart i would say like
he's a little navali for like the crypto
world he's like pseudosynonymous a
little bit in the vault right so
so he has this he has his threat he goes
uh here's how i think about um
about making it or like wealth basically
he goes level one crushed by
circumstances these are like refugees in
syria you're born in a civil war in the
congo
unfortunately billions of our like come
you know comrades in life don't even
have the faintest opportunity to make it
because they were born in you know for
circumstances outside their control they
were born into like very very tough
situations he goes for me he goes this
this feels like this makes me feel funny
inside uh i'm paraphrasing for it but it
makes it makes me feel funny inside
right like thousands of little kids will
die today and i'm on the internet buying
you know jpegs for for thousands of
dollars um you know because and they
don't have access to a 50 cent pill that
could like end their agony and like give
them like you know some peace and
they're you know their dreams are being
cut short because they don't have access
to basic you know water or sanitation
and medicine he goes
because level one is not a um it's not a
like niceness problem it's a
coordination problem he goes literally
everybody on earth would skip having a
soda today
you know and they would just have a
glass of water instead if they knew it
would save that kid's life if that three
bucks could go to the kid's life instead
for that coffee or that soda that you
would skip
but the systems are not placed in order
for us to be able to just push that
button easily and have that outcome
happen he goes for for now society
hasn't fixed this
this tweet alone i thought was like one
of the most insightful
and maybe i'm just a [__] sucker for
this [__] but like
when he said this it rang so true to me
that yes we all in the like privileged
world
would happily skip over a cup of coffee
or more
just i skipped that that money goes into
this thing it actually saves this person
but like
we need the coordination we need the
certainty we need we need a lot of
people to do it
for that effect to happen and then we
need the money to actually go to the
right place and then we need to see the
result
in order for us to actually like fix
these problems at scale so i thought wow
if you want to go work on a startup idea
solve that make it so that lots of
people can very easily skip this thing
and that they can that money actually
gets the result done and then everybody
sees the result of it and it would bring
so much gratification that we would all
want to do it again um okay so that's
one tweet then he goes all right
if you're at level one maybe crushed by
circumstances you're not reading these
tweets i have no solutions to level one
i hope humans progress and we can solve
level one we can reduce level one
problems every year if you're if you're
ordering your key point if you're
reading this tweet you've already made
it past level one keep going all right
level two is the struggle is real this
is where day to day you have financial
problems they're kind of finance is like
a stress for you you might have a job or
two you don't have much in terms of
savings
you worry about if you had an emergency
where would you find the money to pay
for it if a car breaks down it can cause
a cascading set of crises and problems
just because you didn't have enough
money buffer if you're in level two and
you're in good health do everything
possible to get out of level two work
overtime take another job push harder
right now because just getting out of
level two to level three the life change
is massive
uh when money problems are like front
and center in your life or that stress
lingers in your head all day it is a tax
on your happiness and your productivity
and unlike level one there's a lot of
people in level two that i know and have
been there in life and have gotten out
and if you can escape do everything
possible to do so
uh he goes here's my my practical advice
if another if you're in level two and
you might own something like an nft that
if you sold it it would move you into
level three just absolutely sell it
right now and get out of level two uh
the life benefits versus level two and
level three are huge
and he goes level three middle class
in the u.s everybody thinks they're
middle class i think this is so true um
if you're if you're making 50 000 a year
in ohio you think you're middle class if
you're making 500 000 in san francisco
you think you're middle class
so uh despite the fact that there is a
definable middle class and he's like for
you know for simplicity let's just call
it this you got a house you have a car
you have some some savings but you don't
have enough where you have like [__] you
money you can't just buy whatever you
want and you don't really know how
you're gonna pay for big things down the
road bigger house college et cetera
um
i spent most of this guys talking to you
guys i spent most of my life my life in
middle class it's a great happy place to
be if you're there don't keep looking up
at the people who have more first be
appreciative that you're not in level
two or level level one where you're
crushed by circumstances you have a
great life you're in the top one percent
of anybody who has ever lived on earth
uh that is very true
he goes level four i call this we like
nice things he's like this is where he
goes this is anything from like the up
the top end of middle class to like the
uber rich and it's a state of mind it's
not a specific income level your basic
life issues are sorted and now you just
buy things you enjoy
this might be like a trip a vacation a
hou a second house or it might be a
private jet there's an endless
playground of [__] to buy and however
much you earn you can spend it there's
enough things to go by congratulations
once again you've made it you're now in
the 0.01
percent of people who have ever lived on
planet earth and then he starts talking
about like
you know but level four is tricky um you
think it brings you a lot more happiness
it doesn't really in fact sometimes it
brings more stress or this anxiety that
you you you got it all and you're still
not happy and um here you go so actually
level three kind of only had upsides
compared to level two but level four
actually has some traps if you made it
to level four congrats you know like um
here's my take you know you get you
really want to get to level you want to
be first he says be honest with yourself
no he goes first do all the things go to
paris rent a boat upgrade your flight to
business class
check out how level 4 lives he goes then
ask yourself are you happier did this
bring you joy which of those things
brought you joy what was the is it the
stuff is it the experiences what felt
great what doesn't like ask yourself
those questions it goes level five is
when you're post consumption where you
no longer care about the [__] you can
buy you're just caring about sort of
like how you choose to spend your time
you want to spend your time in ways that
bring you like peace and happiness for
some people that's a small house and a
truck on a farm in wyoming for other
people that's you know living large you
know in new york and being a power
player and on cnbc every week
don't make any judgments
uh it is what it is just you know figure
out how you want to spend your time are
you playing golf or are you working on
something with a higher purpose for you
the happiest people seem to be the
people that are satisfied through level
five by working on things that
intrinsically motivate them intrinsic
happiness not external goods blah blah
blah blah um
and that's the that's the truth so i was
just curious what's your what's your
take on this that's awesome that's
awesome
is there any part of this by the way he
goes question i get what level is
his username 6529 which is his username
he goes i balance between level four and
five based on how much i enjoy how much
i worry about the world and nice things
i see on instagram any given day i spent
most of my life in level three middle
class loved it my family had brief
moments in level one level two but i was
too young to notice i feel blessed
that's good this is a good ass thread
this could be a book
um
he did a good job i guess you're right
he uh his writing was pretty good if
that's if you read it exactly i was
skimming it and i was like it's
confusing but that's amazing i think
intel hook sucked it was way too much
jargon but the actual content was solid
the one thing i told him i go i dm to my
go this is a great thread it resonates i
go the one thing you're missing is that
there's a moment
somewhere at the top of l3 right before
l4 maybe this is just l4 which is that
you decouple time and money where before
in your life you were always trading
your time to earn money and now you
start trading your time your money to
get more time back
and i said actually i think that's what
level four really is not just being able
to buy all the stuff you want it's the
freedom of time and recognize that and
like get to that point as fast as you
can i think it's this is an interesting
conversation for us because both of us
probably have very recently gone from
three to four and very likely are
not entirely far from four to five
um
and so
but we kind of experienced all that very
we we experienced both all those jumps
like in a in like a
incredibly short amount of time
um can i do my wannabe naval thing for a
second yeah so we were right we were
level three when we first met you know
last seven eight years of our life and
then probably in the last two years when
i sold my company and you sold yours
is when we jumped into level four and if
we the naval thing is basically we got
financial freedom which meant we don't
have to like worry about money anymore
um but then we need uh freedom from
finance which is level five which is
when you stop making decisions
based on money and i think that's what
the truly wealthy people do is they
choose how to spend their time not
because of the financial outcome at all
but look bro listen listen though let's
let's no longer pulls at them
let's be real here though
we just first of all we're getting paid
stupid money to just sit here and shoot
the [__] second of all we just shot the
[__] about you taking the week off to
learn so like we're not are like maybe
that is five
or is that four it is five but at the
same time why am i doing this ecommerce
business is it because it lights my soul
on fire every day no it's because there
was an opportunity and i'm trying to
capitalize on it and it's working and
now i don't want to give it up because i
think it's going to be super successful
and i like i like feeling like i'm
successful i like winning i like when a
project works and i like the money that
comes with it and so like there are
still and i like the way he said he
bounces between them it's not like when
you're at a level well then 100 of your
decisions and you 100 of your life you
you're you're acting that way it's not
you you like fluctuate between these
things and i personally have not been
able to like
let go of
like i i haven't been able to remove
money from my kind of like core
decision-making criteria of why to do
something or not do something it's still
there that means i'm not actually free
from it because it's still like part of
the contract part of the part of the
thing i'm optimizing for whereas i know
some people who don't do that
who
like michael burch uh right who's my
main investor i got to work with him sit
next to him every day
he he does something he invests he does
things that will make money he thinks
he's you know he gets excited when an
investment or business starts to work
and makes money but
when we were deciding what to do in any
really any given case like
i feel like money was like i don't know
12th on the list of things he would
think about
is he a billionaire you think or he's
probably
he may not be but it doesn't matter he
goes most people that you think are
billionaires are not not quite there
but it doesn't matter it's probably not
that you know what's there between 500
and a billion right um yeah
and so um
do you think he
so the the weird thing that i've noticed
is when you when money
is now no longer part of the equation
it's kind of depressing because you're
like [__] this has been like the goal
the whole time and now like my
decision-making process has totally
changed
it's kind of a weird spot and so is he
depressed do you think because of that
because like he's the same motivating
factor isn't there anymore and he's like
oh man now i'm like changed
no he's happy he's really happy but he
did tell me he goes actually he didn't
tell me this okay the reason the
billionaire conversation came up is
because the bbc did a documentary called
how to be a billionaire yeah by the way
your boy has a camera a cameo in it i
saw a minute or two um i don't know
where this thing plays it's like on
airplanes so sometimes i'll get a
picture somebody sends me their head
rest as they're watching this
documentary and then i popped into it
and so like you know because they're
talking it's about michael it's not
about me but like there's they follow
four people that are billionaires i
think he told me three of the four he
goes i don't think are actually
billionaires himself included and he
goes
he says something in there he goes yeah
when we sold bibo and we had like you
know
all of a sudden all this wealth he goes
it's obviously great and like you know
but kind of anticlimactic like i had
more fun building it than i did selling
it and he goes um
you know the weird thing was that
anytime i felt like not so good like if
i felt sad or whatever like nobody wants
to hear it right like
what's the most annoying thing in the
world an unhappy billionaire and i think
he said something like that i was like
wow that's so true actually like if he
came to me about being glum and whatever
it would be hard for me and my initial
reaction to be like dude you have it all
and it's like that's what a person of
the third world would say to me and
that's what a crippled person would say
to that person in the third world like
this there's a never-ending chain of
looking at somebody and saying you're
unhappy you have it all and so he did
say there was time such people where
they were kind of like well what do we
do now and um that was a little bit
weird and you can be unhappy for other
parts of your life that money doesn't
solve those problems and uh whether it's
like relationships or other stuff that
can happen too but since i've known him
which was a few years after he sold it
he is extremely happy and at peace he
doesn't have like fomo or this itchiness
to like go prove himself and all this
stuff i didn't see it at least um and
then he worked on projects that gave him
joy so like he loves building like
buying real estate buying buildings and
like designing a space and having people
use that space so what that's why our
office was so pimped out because he just
loved the idea of building a dream
office and coming to work in it every
day and having you know this is the
perfect playground to go work in he did
that with the battery bought a 60 000
square foot old candy factory
retrofitted it and then put you know
turned into willy wonka's factory he
made all the rooms unique and fun to be
in and that project was never going to
make money in fact everybody told him
dude you're burning so much money doing
this is such a bad financial move he's
like well that's okay it's not a
financial move
how did that end you know what was it
he got well he built a dope space it had
like the who's who our members like
through it he's made all these made all
these different connections like you
know when justin bieber comes down and
beyonce they stay there and you know
elon musk hangs out there like dude i'm
pretty sure i was i'm pretty sure i was
there one time and i saw
a monk and snoop dogg sitting at a booth
together
yeah dude it's crazy you could bump into
a lot of people there uh you know i saw
leonardo dicaprio walk in i was like oh
[__] leo um but you know it's not just
that the fame like obviously like i
think that i think that side still pulls
to him i think the social side obviously
he does a lot of things to like maximize
the social game but it's not financial
so he had told me once he's like
he's like yeah this thing cost a lot of
money to build and we we blew our budget
on like trying to make it a dope space
uh he's like but my thing was my rule
was like okay once it's operational i
don't mind if i never get my capex back
as long as the opex doesn't continually
bleed more and more money every year and
that's what it got to where the opex
basically the membership and the the
fees of the fee the membership dues plus
the restaurant bar and all that cover
the cost of running it so while he may
never get a positive return on actually
almost certainly will never get a
positive return on the
i don't know maybe maybe 100 million he
put into like the building and
the build out i don't know what it was
but like
i wouldn't be shocked if it was 50 to
100 million uh i don't think he'll ever
get that back but it doesn't believe
money now and so he's like happy with
that so yeah anyways i don't know long
story short he's super happy he goes he
goes on trips to africa all the time
where like he doesn't just give money to
charity water he goes there he visits
the villages he stays there in a tent
and he like experiences that he brings
his whole family with them and that's
like their favorite time of the year is
when they get to go to like rural africa
sleep in a tent you know and uh and live
in this village and then like bring help
bring like better work life conditions
to the people there
well that's badass do we want to um
do we want to end there or what do you
want to do
yeah we can end there because uh somehow
we went pretty long they told us to keep
these under 45 minutes for youtube but
uh i have a feeling it's gonna be hard
for us to do that
that's all right this one was maybe
extraordinary i i i was i was
long-winded yeah
well all right this idea you said
something about let's do one more uh
panic attacks you said you've had panic
attacks and you started you asked
twitter for panic attack help this gave
me an idea but first tell me your panic
attack thing and then i'll tell you my
idea so i've had panic attacks since the
seventh grade i remember the exact day
it was the third day of school at 8 55
pm i had this weird thought where i
thought like what's outside of the world
and like
if you like you go into space you just
like keep going and like there's nothing
out there and we're meeting and i
remember i if i flipped out and i got
panicky i went to the doc i went to the
downs to the nurse i was like my heart
i'm having a heart attack i can't
breathe like i do and so ever since then
i've had i've been very panicky and i
get a panic attack i have very very
distinct triggers and i take daily
medication and like a xanax for that i
keep with me just in case so like
anything that involves tight spaces that
i can't get out of or uh like being
really deep in the wilderness and i
can't get out of i flip out and i hate
it so i get crazy panic attacks because
of it so like when we fly i'm very
medicated um i just i can't stand very
claustrophobic i don't go in elevators
or i try not to i don't like rooms
without windows and i don't take the
subway
okay and when you get a panic attack
what do you do
i keep medication on me at all times and
i'll take one pill um if i didn't take
that pill it feels like i'm dying like i
feel like i want to kill myself like i'm
like my heart is is going so hard uh i
feel like i feel like i'm dying i feel
like i'm about to die i literally think
the world's gonna end and i like i'm
flipping out
okay that's crazy i've never experienced
something like that my buddy had one in
college while we were he was sitting
nationals were playing halo and then
like he was doing something else and he
had a panic attack and like we called an
ambulance and it was the first time i've
ever heard this and at the time i was
like bro just relax like yeah it's hard
it's like right that was my time it's
like telling it it's like telling a drug
addict like dude just don't do heroin
right i know i know that's like i didn't
understand it and um it was my first
time experiencing it yeah it sounded
like a heart attack like all his
symptoms were like a heart attack
symptoms
and so uh one thing i wanted to share
with you somebody had tweeted this and i
saw that emmett who was my my manager at
the time but he's the ceo of twitch he
had tweeted this back somebody said
tweeted to me
no no somebody had tweeted this out they
go
any advice on how to help someone
experiencing anxiety and potentially
panic attacks relax and ground
themselves i don't have experience with
this
uh blah blah blah and then emmett
randomly replied sorry sorry
i want to get contacts they retweeted my
tweet
no no this was a tweet i saw two years
ago that your tweet guided me
okay i saw him reply to this and he goes
this may sound weird but the mammalian
diving reflex is triggered by triggered
by submerging your face in cold water
and cuts the panic attack loop can be
very very effective but obviously hard
to do in public have you ever heard of
this
no but i would love i would be
interested in it so then he linked it
and i you know so i went to it so like
here you can uh i'll give you the link
so emmet had panic attacks i think a lot
of high-functioning people get it
because like i think in order to be like
high-tech consume so
or why would because in order to be in
order to be like high-functioning and
successful often times you're motivated
you're like you're you're neurotic right
you're motivated by some anxiety driven
thing and i imagine there's a huge
correlation between the two
so i'm looking at it so basically my
understanding so i look i remember
reading this two years ago when you
tweeted it reminded me of it so um i
remember looking into it and basically
there's uh you just need to change state
so there's a state that triggers the
panic attack and so if you want to undo
the if you want to stop the panic attack
you need to change state that's hard to
change state when you're in a panic
attack and so the when you feel it
coming on this is the thing to do you go
into a very cold uh a very cold ice
water you have to get really cold water
and plunge your face
for 10 to 20 seconds and what that does
is it automatically triggers your heart
rate uh to slow down and your um your
blood gets sort of like centered around
your core
and that will short-circuit the the
panic attack loop and so for you or
anybody else who has this that's good i
don't know how you would try this but
but try it
well it's not that bad it looks like
there's like an example of a guy in his
kitchen with just a bowl of ice water
like i get him in the middle at night
sometimes i'll wake up and i'm like
what's going on where am i and i start
flipping out uh and he shows his
heartbeat right going from 103 beats per
minute to 47 beats per minute after just
20 seconds with his face in the thing
so this guy so okay so by the way 103
beats per minute just from a panic
attack that's pretty wild that's a
that's a high that's a high heart rate
it's hard like i can't make my heart
rate go that high just sitting still
right now
isn't like resting heart rate like 70 to
90 or something like that
it should be less than 70 yeah
uh okay so that was the first thing that
came to mind the second thing was
um
uh patients like me so the thing you did
where you were like i have this thing
and like people have kind of like an
aversion to going to the doctor in
general right some people don't go
because of cost some people don't go
because of convenience some people don't
go because they don't like the doctor
some people don't go because they just
want to feel they are worried they're
going to get diagnosed with something
and they just they'd rather be a
blissful ignorance
and
patience like me has always been this
thing that fascinated me are you
familiar with patients like me
no i'm looking it up
it's this community
it's where you find other people that
have the same condition medical
condition that you do so let's say you
have some rare form of leukemia you will
find a group of other people with the
same form leukemia and then you could go
there and like maybe in your real life
you can't find anybody who can empathize
with you or share ideas or share
suffering or share you know
uh in this there's a bunch of other
people going through the same thing as
you which is one of the most
bonding experiences there is is going
through suffering that uh going through
a unique suffering that other people
have gone through and so i think these
groups are probably incredibly valuable
to the person and also sticky as a
product now they've raised 150 million
dollars which tells me that this is a
real like business opportunity but our
patients like me has been around for a
long time
i bet that there's an opportunity to
like reboot the sort of like patients
like me idea and just do it simpler more
mobile-friendly
and i think you'd be doing a lot of good
in the world plus be building a very
valuable
app
around community where and maybe you
could start this with facebook groups
you know there are lots of facebook
groups for people who have certain
conditions
um and and i think there's probably a
way to bootstrap this but i think this
is a really valuable company to build
both in terms of the value to science
how does this make money value as a
business
i don't know how patients like me makes
money i don't know if they you know have
like
sort of like you know pharmaceutical
companies sponsor certain things or i
don't know what they i don't know what
they do as far as that goes maybe it's a
paid membership i don't know i'm
assuming people would pay
once they find some value in the
community for like maybe premium
education or
like a member's lounge or something like
that
um i'm not sure how they make money but
i do think that these are
probably very very valuable and the
thing you did where you just kind of go
ask if you want other people who have
had
similar who have the similarities the
the response is crazy right i've gotten
a hundred and dms
exactly because if you if you've
experienced something like the way i
felt the urge to share with you this a
solution like this is what happens
whether it's like hey my pet won't eat
well you know i have a maltipoo and
she's picky eater i've tried everything
any help and it's like people will
[__] come to the rescue on facebook
and be like
here is like a 10-part guide i just
created for you because i went through
that too and i found something that
actually works and so there's this very
strong
psychology around that so i think that
there's an opportunity to reboot
patients like me i would use google
adwords because i think people go to
google when they have a problem this is
interesting how to stop panic attacks
and i would just use adwords to uh to
grow this thing and try to get like
you know each niche uh thing to have
like you know tens of thousands of
members inside what calls it like the
crazy crew
um crazy crew.co
uh this is awesome i've never seen this
i got to research this maybe that's a
good idea yeah i mean i got so many
disease things right dude when you had
your lyme disease problem who saved you
you put it out there in public like i
got this [__] thing
and then somebody was like yo
i got you she's yeah i got you and then
she gave you like the miracle cure and
then you're like fine now right like
you literally kind of got your life
saved through doing something yeah yeah
the lady i told the story lady oh i
don't even know bought me a 25 000
treatment and i uh she didn't even know
who i was it was it was wild i'm gonna
have to research held
yeah all right well good suggestion i'm
gonna research this i've never heard of
this i've never heard of so many of
these things mental agility and uh
patients like me what a crazy business i
have to research it um all right i think
that's the episode we'll see if this is
gonna be good this is our longest
episode ever i think
yeah this one went awhile all right
we're out here
[Music]
never looking back